so you remember the Paul Pelosi break-in
Nancy Pelosi is out of town 9-1-1 call
at the Pelosi residence in San Francisco
cops come Paul Pelosi is a according to
the reports in his boxers and then
there's this guy who I guess broke in
but Paul Pelosi doesn't seem concerned
and then according to reports Paul
Pelosi said that he knew the guy
referred to him as a friend
that that Paul Pelosi didn't rush to the
cops when they got there and then
finally the guy attacked Paul Pelosi
with a hammer but all sorts of theories
based on the Press reports well now we
got the video footage
the cops show up to the door it's
unclear who opens the door
hi drop the hammer
the guy's Holdings hands and the guy and
that guy just attacks Paul blows through
the Hem
[Applause]
so it's a little bit weird here you
don't we don't really know who opens the
door it's called Pelosi they're standing
somewhat still he's got a drink it could
be just a glass of water in one hand and
then his arm is being held by this this
Invader in the other hand the invader
then has the hammer on the other hand
and they're all just standing there and
the cops go hey what's going on here so
your first thought is why didn't the
cops tackle this guy this guy's holding
a hammer
he's holding a hammer
while holding Paul Pelosi the husband of
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives and the cops are just
waiting they're like hey what's going on
hey man Drop The Hammer drop the hammer
the guy's got a hammer he's got the
husband of the speaker of the house I
bet you jump on him I bet you shoot him
how about you do something are you
standing there and then they wait and
then the guy just slowly takes a hammer
out and smacks Paul Pelosi on the head
so that's bad enough it's weird though
because there are still questions why
doesn't Paul Pelosi seem
uh more nervous why doesn't who open the
door what do these guys know each other
what what is this do the cops not know
that this is Paul Pelosi but then we get
the 9-1-1 call and Things become much
clearer
this is San Francisco police do you need
help
oh what is the gentleman uh uh here just
waiting for my wife to come back
nasty Pelosi okay do you need to please
fire a medical for anything eight
seconds uh I I don't think so I don't
think so I've got a problem but he's
utilities took zero okay okay
no no this this element just uh came
into the house uh and he wants to wait
here for my wife to come home and so uh
anyways do you know who the person is
no I don't know who it is he uh
he has this is
not to uh he told me not to do anything
anyway this gentleman says
yeah he told me to put the phone down
and you see what he said my name's David
his name is David
okay and who is David I I don't know
right I'm a friend of theirs
yeah I I um he says he's a friend but
you don't know who he is no it's no mess
he's telling me I'm being very leading
so I I gotta stop talking to you okay
okay you sure I can stay on the phone
with you just to make sure
you get fell off the phone
okay okay
thank you okay bye
so this goes that's just a brief snippet
of it the CL the the call goes on and
the longer the call goes on the angrier
one becomes
at the incompetence of this dispatcher
because hey I'm here there's a guy in my
house I don't know him he says he's
going to wait for my wife Nancy Pelosi
um she goes oh yeah okay do you need
emergency services or no okay and I
later on she goes okay we'll call back
if you need anything he's going no I
don't
what do you no why and you you realize
that Paul Pelosi is telegraphing as
clearly as he possibly can that they
need to send someone immediately and
this incompetent dispatcher it is ready
to hang up the phone he said no no don't
hang what are you and and you can hear
the guy
the guy comes in he says hey I'm a
friend I don't I don't know him but he
says that he's a friend of ours and and
she almost hangs up so
this dispels the conspiracy theories
right now go to hallow.com Knowles if
you are listening to this show you
probably know how important I consider
religion and our faith lives that is why
I'm super duper excited to talk to you
about hallow hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app and the number one
Catholic app in the world I love hallow
the app as everything that I need to
maintain a daily prayer routine it's got
over 6 000 audio guided prayers
meditations and peaceful music playlists
plus daily reminders will encourage you
to keep up with the routine you know how
much I love father Mike schmitz's Bible
into your podcast it's really the only
podcast I regularly listen to you can
listen to it on Hello
you can pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel or Jonathan roomie who plays
Jesus in the new hit series The Chosen
just like physical exercise daily
spiritual exercise is critical to your
well-being you are supposed to be holy
and you can't be holy if you don't pray
it's especially true in a world that
that attacks faith and religion
constantly try hallow for three months
for free at hallow.com Knowles
the conspiracy theories were popular as
he knew the guy they one conspiracy
theory was that they were gay lovers the
uh there were all sorts of theories
floating around the internet and
the the reason that theories were
floating around the internet
is not because
right-wingers are insane
the reason the theories were floating
around the internet is because that was
the information that was reported the
information that was reported was that
this guy that Paul Pelosi referred to
this guy as a friend
that that the police on another one of
the dispatcher transcripts says that
that this guy was a friend of Pelosi
the Pelosi was cool and calm and
collected didn't rush to the police had
a drink in his hand had his pants off
all of the leaks
before this information came out
suggested that these guys had some kind
of a relationship so then the question
is
who released the information who was
behind the leaks and the answer is it
was only it was the cops
the cops are the only ones that had and
the the political leadership of the cops
they're the only ones that had the tapes
so you had on the one hand you had the
left-wing theory that this was a right
winger a trump Republican he's obviously
not he was a nudist with a gay pride
flag at one of the compounds that he was
living at he's an illegal alien he's
obviously completely insane so that
theory goes out the window then you have
the the right wing theory on the fringes
that this guy was
I don't know a gay lover or something
like that but that one goes out and so
you had the left and the right bickering
with each other when really what is
revealed by the 911 tape is
this was the cops covering up for their
incompetence
very very bad week for cops in this
country
now what's the solution to that there
are really only two solutions I think
listening to this kind of incompetence
and then especially looking at the
outrage that people see from from the
police involved killing of Tyree Nichols
either you can just disband the police
either the libs were right abolish the
police these guys are or
fund the police much better train them
much better exclude people from the
force who are not up to the job fire
that dispatcher fire the cops who
improperly responded to the the Pelosi
call and and just or train them or just
get get
much better policing I think the answer
is obviously the latter
it can't be the former because contrary
to what the libs and the sort of anarcho
libertarian kind of right-wing Libs
would have you believe the civil
government exists to protect Law and
Order we need it we need Law and Order
we need a civil authority to have a
flourishing Society
because we're not just free-floating
atoms left to do what we want we'll all
build up our own private armies that's
not real that's never happened anywhere
that's a utopian fantasy what what
we need is Law and Order and so if
that's the basis of a society then we
need good strong police departments with
good training and high standards and
legal protections for the cops so they
don't have their lives ruined by
political correctness if they are
involved in a Justified police involved
killing which very often what happens
now is police are involved in a
Justified killing a Justified shooting
and then they go to prison and then or
they get their lives ruined in some
other way they lose their careers they
lose their pensions and so a lot of good
people a lot of good competent people
say why would I ever want to be a cop
there's no political defense of me it's
a dangerous job and I could lose my life
if I trespass against the virtues of
political devices of political
correctness
so then then you end up in a bad
situation you end up in a very bad
Personnel situation today is music
Monday the rest of the show continues
now Mr Davies and the producing team
has some really profound music for me to
analyze because you know I am a cultural
Maven I am this the hip-hop pippity pop
kind of music man over here you don't
want to miss it become a member and use
code knowleskin to wlas at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
we'll see you over there
[Music]
foreign